once again the relevance of the
parliamentary work in support of our
partnerships says it several time not
only with the Eastern partners but also
with other partners we have around the
world the role of parliament is s key I
believe that's when it comes to the
Eastern Partnership specifically both
the partnership dimension the six of
those countries but also specifically on
the parliamentary work you've done and
also the work you've done with the civil
society and the social players that have
roots in each of the six specific
countries the added value is enormous
enormous and I can only say obviously I
cannot this is quite an unusual session
for debates for me because obviously I
cannot commit for the future steps that
will be obviously in the wise hands of
my successor and the next commission but
I am sure that the track that has been
started wisely ten years ago and then
followed in this most recent years that
of deepening our partnership in all
fields with the six countries we have at
our East is going to be strengthened
even more in the future and I am sure
that it will can it will have the
possibility of counting on your full
support as I have been privileged to be
accompanied in this particular work by
you with your advisers with your work
and many of you have thanked me for this
partnership well let me play back by
thanking you because indeed I think that
we have shown that indeed even if not
always sharing the same exactly the same
perspectives but that's the the positive
point of democracy you can disagree on
some points but you can still work in
the same direction on some issues and I
think that in particular on the Eastern
Partnership we've proven that
Parliament's Commission Council can work
together in unison and try to bridge
some of the difficulties that are still
lying ahead again thank you for for this
five years of support on this file and
looking forward to stay in touch but as
I was mentioning to the previous
president of the session I stay with you
for the rest of the evening and tomorrow
so that's not that's not yet the last
word of goodbye
Thank You Kirsten I'm safe am as a la
vita Coletti some say Chuck or saga a
bond to attain a fella me natural as our
own boss a banker Sonoma Raceway tad
Shakalaka vodkas on appeal and upon
retiring card a libido check uni Okuda
bestows a critical few official arena
con helado SATA is ravenous paulistinha
bond tobacco's a totally [ __ ] key a
Lockwood has a true